rebeca andrade es la gran sensación de
la gimnasia artística aquí en tokio 2020
la brasileña de 22 años consiguió el oro
en la final del salto con otro fue más
que la esquina de la estadounidense
quien está sustituyendo a simon wells
quien se quedó con la medalla de plata y
yo seguida de corea consiguió el bronce
andrade que consigue este su segunda
medalla porque se había quedado con la
plata en el ejercicio completo en tenis
el alemán alexander es breve es el nuevo
campeón olímpico tras vencer a heart en
la novela 'el ruso' en 6 361
y por último pues hoy fue ya las últimas
competiciones de natación aquí en el
tokyo y bueno se dos nadadores se
consolidaron por una parte la
australiana en anda aquí aunque
consiguió un total de siete medallas
cuatro de ellas en oro y calibre son del
estadounidense de 24 años quien
consiguió cinco medallas doradas